[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  hey when I started this I supported oh  it's a Brian Conan O'Brien I'm him the  comedian TV host doing a big show okay  we have a new policy Americans are  subject to extreme very extreme  rivetting  you might just be one of those bad  hombres I see what you're doing all  right we got some new people running the  United States and that's created some  tension between our countries you can't  lump all Americans into one group it's  not fair  stereotyping gracias thank you so much  I wasn't sure if you guys would have  steak there like 15 years ago  okay and I stole the towel and I'll just  see myself blue the border this is a  great  [Applause]